Merhaba sevgili arkadaşlar Türkçe saati
kanalına Hoş geldiniz sizler için
hazırlamış olduğum videolara devam
ediyoruz 3üncü temada kavramları
konuşuyorduk Bu videoda arkadaşlar
hikayede yapı unsurlarından ve
kavramlardan bahsedeceğiz izlek nedir
Konu nedir Olay örgüsü nedir özellikle
hikayelerin bölümleri vardır serim düğüm
çözüm bölümlerinde ya da zaman kavramı
mekan kavramı Şahıs kadrosu nasıldır
kadrodaki bu özellikle kahramanlarımızın
fiziksel özellikleri ruhsal özellikleri
nasıl bulunur bunları konuşacağız
Hazırsanız başlayalım hikayede kavram
lar ve yapı unsurlarında göreceğimiz ilk
başlık sevgili arkadaşlar tema
kavramıdır temanın bir diğer isminin
izlek olduğunu unutmayalım tema ya da
izlek diye adlandırılan unsur bir
metindeki en temel duyguyu ya da
düşünceyi Barındırır arkadaşlar
düşünceyi genelde düşünüyoruz Bir
hikayede Bir metinde ancak duygunun da
bir tema olabileceği Aklımızdan çıkıyor
amana duygular da bizim için bir tema
değerindedir bir izlek değerindedir
Çünkü arkadaşlar biz tema diye Aslında
bir ya da birden fazla yani iki k
kelimeyle ortaya konan daha çok soyut
olan genel bir ifadeyi kapsıyor hikayeyi
okudunuz o hikayede Siz çaresizliğe
hissettiniz O zaman bu hikayenin teması
Çaresizlik dediniz hikayeyi okudunuz
baktınız çocuk ailesinden uzaklaşmış
değil mi gitmiş Filistin'de bir yaban
toprağa orada hiç kimse Türkçe
konuşmuyor kitabınızın ilk hikayesiydi
Ne yaptı çocuk yalnızlığın içerisinde
kendini hapsetti bir baktı orada bir
ayakkabıcı geldi çivileri ağzına
dolduruyor ayakkabıyı tamir ediyor
Çiviler ağzına batmaz mı senin dedi
orada Yüreğiniz paramparça oldu bir anda
doğrudan arkadaşlar İçinizde O çocuğun
yaşamış olduğu kimsesizliği çaresizliği
hissettiniz ve bir coşku da vardı orada
ağlıyordu çocuk mesela hatırlarsınız
kitabınızda direkt okumuştum dolayısıyla
bir duygu da olabilir Merhamet acıma
Ayrılık Yalnızlık geçim sıkıntısı bizim
için Arkadaşlar bir TEM olarak Eee
karşımıza gelebilir Peki konu nedir Konu
şimdi konu hik hikayelerde mutlaka
arkadaşlar olmak zorunda Her hikayenin
bir konusu vardır Her paragrafın bir
konusu vardır bu dersin konusu nasıl
varsa eee bir hikayenin de konusu olmak
zorunda Biz konuyu bir metinde ele
alınan durum Ya da olay olarak
tanımlıyoruz ancak konu temaya göre
arkadaşlar tema daha böyle kapsayıcı ama
konu temaya göre daha kapsamlıdır Yani
daha geneldir arkadaşlar
kapsayıcıdaki
konuyu bulmak için hangi soruyu
soruyoruz bu paragrafta bu met de ne
anlatılıyor sorusunu soruyoruz ve ne
anlatılıyor sorusuna verilen cevap bizim
için o hikayenin o paragrafın konusu
oluyor sevgili arkadaşlar bakın şunlar
Mesela bir Hikayenin konusu olabilir
para kazanmak için köyünden ayrılan
Rıza'nın şehirde yaşadıkları mesela
geçimsiz bir çocuğun sokaktaki kediyle
dostluk kurması Bu da bir konu olabilir
ya da hatasını gizlemek için yalan
söyleyen bir adamın işten kovulunca
yaşadığı pişmanlık bir Hikayenin konusu
olabilir işte sabah kalkıp okula
giderken Başından Geçenler Hikayenin
konusu olabilir eve geldi ders
çalışırken bir anda hissettikleri
paragrafın konusu olabilir Hikayenin
konusu olabilir bunun gibi konu daha
kapsamlı ama tema daha böyle net
duyguları ya da düşünceleri kapsıyor bir
ya da bir iki kelimeden oluşuyor
diyebiliriz sevgili arkadaşlar şimdi
konumuz bu bununla ilgili başka
söyleyecek bir şeyimiz yok geldim
arkadaşlar olay örgüsüne olay örgüsünde
hikaye Her şeyden önce Arkadaşlar bir
olay anlatmaya dayalı bir metindir O
halde yazalım hikaye olay
anlatmaya dayalı bir metindir Yani bir
hikayede çoğunlukla Tabii ki çoğunlukla
hikaye kişilerin başından geçen olaylar
anlatılır değil mi art arda gelişen
olaylar anlatılır Bu yüzden de
arkadaşlar olaylar çoğu kez sıralı bir
biçimde verilir Yani bir olay örgüsü
içerisinde verilir biri başlar biri
biter biri başlar diğeri biter bir
zincirin halkaları gibi art arda gelişen
olaylar zinciri şeklinde zaten
hikayelerimiz ya da öykülerimiz bunu
unutmayacağız Peki olayların gelişme
düzeni olayların ard arda gelmesiyle
ortaya konan akışa Biz ne diyoruz olay
örgüsü diyoruz Evet karşımıza gelecek bu
hikayenin Olay örgüsü nedir diyecek Siz
Öğretmeniniz bir paragraf verecek bir
hikaye anlatacak diyeceksiniz işte
işçilerin fabrikaya girmesi virgül
fabrikaya girip iş başı yapmaları virgül
sonrasında öğle yemeğine çıkmaları
virgül sonra ustabaşının gelmesi arka
arkaya gelişen olaylar detaylar değil
Ustabaşı nasıl görünüyordu işçiler Ne
giymişti falan böyle detaylar değil
olayların arka arkaya sıralanmasına
dikkat edeceksiniz bu tarz eee bir soru
geldiğinde karşınıza Peki bir ik ain
olay örgüsü şuna benzer bir şekilde
verilebilir size bir hikayenin
dinamiğine göre değişir Tabii bu
Zeynep'in bisiklet almak istediğini
söylemesi şimdi Zeynep diyor ki ben
bisiklet almak istiyorum ailesine bunu
söylüyor ailesinin Zeynep'e bisiklet
hediye etmesi ikinci olay Zeynep'in bir
gün bisikleti parka gitmesi 3üncü olay
parkta eski arkadaşlarıyla karşılaşması
4ün olay bisikletin arkadaşına ödünç
vermesi arkadaşın bisikletini getirmesi
Zeynep'in akşam evde babasından zılgıtı
yemesi falan Zeynep'in odasına gidip
ağlaması annesinin gelip Zeynep'i
teselli etmesi falan diye böyle devam
eder Bu arkadaşlar Bu sizin
yaratıcılığınıza bağlı yazarın
yaratıcılığına nasıl bağlıysa nasıl
devam ettirmek istiyorsa o suyun akışını
Siz de böyle devam ettirebilirsiniz ama
ne yaptı art arda gelen olaylar zinciri
bir düzen içeris inde de öyle değil mi
gelişe gelişe Ne yaptı ilerledi İşte biz
buna arkadaşlar ne diyormuş olay örgüsü
diyormuş çok güzel Peki olay örgüsünü
gördük Şimdi serim düğüm çözüm diye
bizim bölümlerimiz var Ancak bu
bölümleri bilmemiz için Arkadaşlar her
şeyden önce bizim bizim bu bölümler
özellikle serim düğüm çözüm bölümlerinin
bir metindeki giriş gelişme sonuç
bölümlerinin hikayeye ve Roman gibi
anlatmaya bağlı Aslında metinlerdeki
karşılığı olduğunu bileceğiz Yani biz
bir paragrafta Hani paragrafın giriş
cümlesi şudur gelişme cümleleri
şunlardır sonuç cümlesinde artık
toparlayıcı olarak yazar şunları
söylemiştir diyoruz ya işte biz bir
hikayede de o giriş gelişme sonucu
Aslında ne yapıyoruz hikayede ve romanda
yani Anlatmaya bağlı türlerde arkadaşlar
metinlerde serim düğüm çözüm adlarını
veriyoruz sadece isimler böyle değişiyor
Peki şimdi burası çok önemli buraya
büyük böyle beş yıldız 10 numara beş
yıldız bir simge koyalım En azından ne
kadar önemli olduğu görün hikayede serim
düğüm çözüm bölümleri Arkadaşlar nokta
nokta olarak isimlendirilen klasik
hikaye tarzında yer alır bir Şimdi şunu
unutma klasik hikaye tarzı dediğimiz
tarz nedir Arkadaşlar bunu renkli yapmak
isterim renkli oldu olay hikayesinde
arkadaşlar olay hikayesi olarak
isimlendirilen klasik hikaye tarzıdır
olay hikayeleri klasiktir tüm dünya
edebiyatında klasik tarzdır klasik
hikaye anlatımıdır bu da yer alır dikkat
ancak modern hikaye olarak ifade edilen
durum hikayelerinde yani kesit bildiren
değil mi bir kesit anlatan durum
hikayelerinde arkadaşlar Ne Yapmaz bu
bölümler olmaz çok önemli bizim için
önemli bir ayrıntıdır Neden Çünkü olay
hikayesinde art arda gelişen olaylar
vardır birbirine bağlı olarak birbirini
etkileyen olaylar vardır durum
hikayesinde olay yoksa zaten bir durum
anlatıyor bir kesit anlatıyor sana
birazdan konuşacağız zaten şimdi
hikayede kişilerin olayı tanıtıldığı
kişilerin olayın Hatta şöyle diyelim
olayı olayın diyelim Neyi ekleyelim
buraya tanıtıldığı bölümdür bu bölüm
giriş niteliğindedir kişi mekan ve zaman
unsurları çoğunlukla bu bölümde verilir
Biz Bu bölüme ne diyoruz arkadaşlar
Serim diyoruz Serim bölümü diyoruz Peki
geldim bir diğerine diğer bölümüme
hikaye merak unsurunun belirginleştiği
çatışmanın ki çatışmayı ilk dönemde
gördünüz bu dönemde sorumlusunuz bazen
böyle şey oluyor Tabii hocam ama biz
bunu ilk dönem gördük Evet gördünüz hala
görüyorsunuz ve bir daha göreceksiniz
yani sarmal bir şekilde Arkadaşlar aynı
kavramları bir döneme yayıyor Eee Milli
Eğitim Bakanlığı dolayısıyla bir kavramı
birinci dönem ilk sınavda gördük bitti
değil bütün yıl boyunca aslında
görüyorsunuz Bu kavramları kazanım
olarak da çıktı olarak da özellikle
Bunlar veriliyor Dolayısıyla aynı
şeyleri bir daha bir daha dinleyip E ben
tekrara düşüyorum Hoca tekrara düşüyor
demeyin Bunlar bilinçli yapılan bir
tercihtir uygulamadır MEB tarafından
bilerek size her metinde bunları
sezdirim zaman doğrudan gözünüze sokarak
da soruyor haberiniz olsun peki hikayede
merak unsurunun belirlendiği
belirginleşti çatışmanın ortaya çıktığı
bölüme Biz ne diyoruz arkadaşlar düğüm
bölümü diyoruz yani gelişme cümleleri
gibi düşünebilirsiniz bu bölümde olaylar
daha karmaşık bir hale geliyor
okuyucunun heyecanı iyice artıyor Peki
hikayede olayın sonuçlandırıldı bölüme
Biz ne diyoruz arkadaşlar serim düğüm ne
sonuç Evet o zaman arkadaşlar Hatta
sonuç demeyelim Çünkü Cümlede Anlama
girer o çözüm diyelim biz daha doğru
olur çözüm bölümdür bu bölümde
arkadaşlar çatışmalar üzerine çatışmalar
iyice çözüme ulaştırılır bütün sorunlar
Hall olur anlaşmazlıklar giderilir Ve
okuyucunun merakı ne yapar burada
giderilir sevgili arkadaşlar şimdi bir
diğer kavramım olay örgüsünden sonraki
bir diğer kavramım zaman unsuru sevgili
arkadaşlar zaman olay çevresinde gelişen
metinlerde olayın gerçekleştiği dönemdir
andır mevsimdir ya da gündür bir zaman
kavramını size doğrudan da verebilir
cümlelerde ya da onu size böyle e zamanı
çağrıştıran bazı kelimelerle verebilir
mesela yapraklar dökülüyordu diyebilir
yapraklar dökülürken Gemi Limana yanaştı
der yani Sonbahar gibi bir şey dersiniz
gibi Güneşin batmasına yakın bir vakitte
otobüs den ind bakın zaman ne Güneşin
batmasına yakın bir vakit gördüğünüz
gibi zaman var ne diyor İncirler Olana
Kadar diyor ne zaman İncirler Olana
Kadar ne yapıyor orada zamanı
sınırlandırıyor arkadaşlar mekan
hikayenin bir diğer unsurlarından biri
mekan yani yer olay çevresinde gelişen
metinlerde olayın gerçekleştiği çevredir
yerdir Burası bir dış çevre olabilir bir
iç çevre olabilir iç mekan olabilir bir
oda olabilir Bir yazıhane olabilir Park
olabilir bahçe olabilir e okyanusun
ortası olabilir gökyüzünde herhangi bir
işte e gezegende olabilir bir olay değil
mi herhangi bir yerde gerçekleşebilir
arkadaşlar hayali de olabilir Tabii ki
dere kenarında çamaşır yıkayan kadınlar
bir yandan da neşe içinde sohbet
ediyorlardı bakın nerede dere kenarında
gördüğünüz gibi yer belirtilmiş
Öğretmeniniz size yazıldığı bir paragraf
verip bir hikaye verip bu parçadaki yer
ve zaman kavramlarını örnekleriyle
açıklayınız der birden fazla yer
bulabilirsiniz birden fazla zaman
kavramı verebilirsiniz Arkadaşlar sabah
ezan okunurken Çıktık evden ne zaman
sabah ezan okunurken Öğleye geldiğinde
çoktan işleri halletmiş tik ne zaman
Öğleye geldiğinde ne yapıyor birden
fazla zamanı verebiliyor metinlerde
olabilir arkadaşlar Yeter ki Uyanık olun
sabitlenmeyen bir yerde sadece foks lanı
kalmayın başka yerlerde de çıkabilir
Bunu unutmayın Peki geldim şahıs ve kişi
kadrosuna Arkadaşlar şimdi şahıs ve kişi
kadrosu Aslında bizim kişilerim tamamen
o hikayedeki kişiler kişi de olabilir
tek bir kişi de olabilir birden fazla
kişi de olabilir Biz bunu Arkadaşlar bu
olayları yaşayan kişiler olarak tabii ki
görüyoruz hikayelerde mutlaka bir baş
kşi vardır bir başkahraman vardır Bu baş
kahramanın çevresinde gelişen olaylar
yan karakterlerle birlikte Eee ele
alınabilir mesela Kamran Şaşkın şaşkın
yüzüme bakmakta devam ediyordu Çalı Kuşu
Yine anlamadım Feride bu anlayışsızlığı
Hayret eder gibi bir jest yaptım
dudaklarımı büzdüm hangi hale
büründüğünü anlattı ama Şahıs kadrosu
kimlerdir derse Kamran ve ferided dir
der geçersiniz burada olay örgüsü kişi
zaman mekan bir hik ayinin yapısal
unsurlarıdır arkadaşlar unutmayacağız
yapısal unsurlarıdır tabii Bir de bizim
hikayelerimiz eki arkadaşlar
karakterlerimiz kahramanlarımızın bazı
özellikleri vardır mesela bu özellikler
ruhsal ve fiziksel özellikler olarak da
karşımıza geliyor özellikle yazılılarda
ilk dönemde de yapmış olabilir
Öğretmeniniz bu dönem de yapabilir Çünkü
hikaye bu dönemde var hatta 4 temada 2
yazıld da romandan da sorumlu
olacaksınız tiyatro falan girecek işin
içine orada da arkadaşlar Eee
karakterlerin yani kahramanların
fiziksel ve ruhsal özel ik lini sizden
örnekleriyle isteyebilir Öğretmeniniz
yazılıda kendi cümlelerinizle
isteyebilir buna dikkat edin doğrudan
Okuduğunuz cümlelerdeki fiziksel
görüntüsüne dair bilgi veriyorsa onları
yazın işte mavi bir şapka takmıştı yeşil
gözleri vardı üstünde beyaz bir gömlek
vardı iri bir gövdesiyle
bunları cımbızla böyle metnin
içerisinden hikayenin içinden Siz
seçeceksiniz örnekleriyle açıklayınız
diyebilir Öğretmeniniz Siz açık
olacaksınız Yazın ne görüyorsanız yazın
yazmayan puan şey puan vermeyen öğretmen
utansın diyeceğiz tamam mı Siz yazın
yani ha abartmayın da Her gördüğünüz
yazın ama çünkü amaç burada bak Ben bunu
görüyorum öğretmenim Sen bana sordun ama
ben de bunları cümlede gördüm ve
yazıyorum kendi cümlem le yazıyorum Eee
özgün bir ifade kullanıyorum hani buna
Özen gösterdiğiniz Öğretmeninizin
görmesi esastır Peki bir hikayede
arkadaşlar kişilerin mutlaka Biz az önce
de söyledik ruhsal ve fiziksel değil mi
ruhsal ve fiziksel özelliklerine yer
verilebilir sadece ruhsal özelliklerine
verebilir tipini hiç bilmeyebilir Biz o
kişinin Sadece tipini anlatıp ruhsal
özelliklerini vermeyebilir yazarın Kendi
tercihidir bazen de ikisi de olur
arkadaşlar ama bütünlükçü bir romanda
Bir hikayede kesinlikle biz ne yapıyoruz
ikisini de görüyoruz sevgili arkadaşlar
Peki bir kişinin iç dünyasıyla
duygularıyla kişiliğiyle ilgili olan
özellikler bizim hangi
özelliklerimizdendir
Saç rengi göz rengi vücut ve ten rengi
görünümüyle ilgili kıyafetiyle ilgili
işte ayakkabısı nasıldı bunlarla ilgili
bize bilgiler veriyorsa uzun boylu bir
adam yanımıza geldi şişman kadın onu
sertçe uyardı zayıfsa hiç ses etmedi
kısa saçlı bir çocuktu falan böyle dış
görünüşünü fiziki özelliklerini
veriyorsa Buna da arkadaşlar ne diyoruz
fiziksel
özellikler diyoruz Evet sarışın olması
mavi gözlü kumral kot pantolon elbiseli
gibi böyle ufak ufak Detaylara
ayrıntılara yer verebilir ya da daha
detaylı verebilir Bunlar da bizim için
fiziksel özelliklerdir diyeceğiz Evet
sevgili arkadaşlar bu bölüm için bu
kadar yeterli bu bölümde sadece
hikayenin unsurlarından kavramlardan
yapısal özelliklerinden bahsetmiş olduk
bundan sonraki videoda yine hikayeye
devam edeceğiz hikaye ile ilgili
kavramlara devam edeceğiz kavramlarımız
da bittikten sonra örnek metinler
Üzerinden tek tek inceleme yapacağız hiç
merak etmeyin önce şu kavramları bir
oturtalım Kendinize dikkat edin bir
diğer videoda görüşene kadar Hoşça kalın